.
THAT'S OUR PRAYER.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU,
SARA CARTER.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
FLORIDA SENATOR MARCO RUBIO.
YOU KNOW, SENATOR, BY THE WAY, I
MEAN WHAT I SAY.
FIRST THINGS FIRST HERE.
THE CASTRO BROTHERS, THIS IS A
MURDEROUS -- MURDERING COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP.
IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
THEY STOLE LAND, THEY OPPRESSED
PEOPLE AND NONE OF THE PROMISES
GIVEN TO THE PEOPLE WERE EVER
FULFILLED.
THAT'S UP FIRST ON THE TABLE.
YOU, LAST NIGHT, HAD TO
EMBARRASS -- IT'S 8:30, STILL NO
WORD FROM JOE.
IT'S 10:30, STILL NO WORD FROM
JOE AND THEN THIS TEPID PATHETIC
STATEMENT HE SENDS OUT TODAY AND
THEN HIS FOLKS AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, THE
WHITE HOUSE, LYING AND SAYING
THIS IS ABOUT COVID.
THAT WAS AN OUTRIGHT LIE.
YOU FORCED THEIR HAND TO EVEN
SAY ANYTHING.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY IT'S SO HARD
TO CRITICIZE MARXISTS.
I DO THINK AND IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
THAT THERE PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
AREN'T SAYING ANYTHING IN THE
PRESIDENT TOOK A WHOLE DAY.
HE STILL LEFT OUT THE WORD
MARXIST AND COMMUNIST AND
SOCIALIST.
WHAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED, THE
MURDEROUS NATURE OF THE CASTRO
REGIME, THAT'S THE WAY EVERY
MARXIST REGIME HAS EVER BEEN,
ALWAYS BECAUSE MARXISM AND
SOCIALISM IS BUILT ON THIS.
THERE'S THIS GROUP OF GOOD,
NOBLE PEOPLE AND THERE'S THIS
GROUP OF OPPRESSORS THAT ARE
TRYING TO DESTROY THEM.
GIVE US THE POWER TO CRUSH THE
OPPRESSORS AND YOU GIVE US POWER
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU
SECURITY, STABLES ECONOMY WITH
THE PRICE OF THAT OF COURSE IS
YOUR FREEDOM SO THEY WIN AND
THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
YOU DON'T GET THOSE THINGS AND
YOU DON'T GET YOUR FREEDOM BACK
AND THEN IF YOU COMPLAIN ABOUT
IT THEY CRACKED HER HEAD OPEN,
THEY PUT YOU IN JAIL, THE EXILE
YOU, OR THEY KILL YOU.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
EVERYWHERE ALL THE TIME.
SOCIALISM IS ABOUT CONTROL,
ABOUT CONTROLLING PEOPLE AND
EVERY ASPECT OF THEIR LIVES AND
THE PASSION YOU SEE IN THE
STREETS OF MIAMI TONIGHT AND IN
OTHER PARTS OF FLORIDA AND THE
COUNTRY ARE PEOPLE THAT SUFFERED
UNDER THAT EVIL, SAW THEIR
FAMILIES DIVIDED, THEIR LIVES
DESTROYED, THEIR KIDS HAVE TO GO
OVERSEAS, PEOPLE NEVER SAW THEIR
PARENTS BEFORE THEY DIED BECAUSE
OF EVIL.
THAT'S WHAT MARXISM IS AND I
WISH WE HAD A PRESIDENT AND MORE
LEADERS IN CONGRESS ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF THE AISLE.
WE HAVE A FEW, BUT NOT ENOUGH
WILLING TO SAY THAT.
>> Sean: WHAT WAYS COULD THE
UNITED STATES HELP THE PEOPLE
NOW ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF LIBERTY
AND FREEDOM THAT THEY WANT.
I KNOW AMERICANS -- GO AHEAD.
[INDISCERNIBLE].
>> FIRST OF ALL MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR WHOSE SIDE WE ARE ON.
AND WHY THEY'RE DOING THIS.
PEOPLE ARE IN THE STREET BECAUSE
THEY WANT LIBERTY FROM MARXISM
AND WE ARE WITH THEM.
NUMBER TWO, MAKE ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR TO THE REGIME IN CUBA THAT
THE TRUMP POLICIES ARE GOING TO
CHANGE, BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY
ARE HOPING IS GOING TO COME OUT
OF THIS.
YOU SEE HOW BAD THINGS ARE HERE,
IF ONLY GUYS WOULD LIFT THE
EMBARGO, LIFT SANCTIONS, MAYBE
THINGS WOULD BE BETTER FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CUBA, COME OUT RIGHT
NOW AND SAY WE ARE DONE WITH OUR
REVIEW, WE ARE KEEPING THE TRUMP
POLICIES THAT ALLOW THE MILITARY
TO ENRICH ITSELF AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE PEOPLE.
NUMBER THREE, MAKE AT THE TOP
PRIORITY OF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
TO PROVIDE INTERNET ACCESS USING
SATELLITE TECHNOLOGY OR WHATEVER
WE CAN GET OUR HANDS ON SO THE
PEOPLE OF CUBA CAN SPEAK TO EACH
OTHER AND SHOW THE WORLD WHAT'S
HAPPENING INSIDE OF CUBA AND THE
FOURTH THING THAT I WOULD DO IS
I WOULD MAKE IT ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
TO THE CASTRO REGIME THAT IF YOU
GUYS THREATEN US WITH MASS
MIGRATION OR IF YOU ENCOURAGE A
MASS MIGRATION, LIKE THE CRISIS
OF A POSTURING 94 THAT IS ACTIVE
HOSTILITY AGAINST THE NIGHT
STATES AND WE ACT ACCORDINGLY.
THOSE FOUR THINGS HAVE TO COME
ACROSS.
>> Sean: MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THE CUBAN GOVERNMENT, TYPICAL
MARXIST DICTATORSHIP, HAS NOW
SHIPPED ON THE INTERNET FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CUBA.
IS THERE WAY WE CAN HELP THEM
GET A BACK UP AND IT FOR THEM?
BECAUSE I THINK TO SHOW
SOLIDARITY FOR THEIR FREEDOM
MOVEMENT --
>> YET, A FULL COURT PRESS,
FIRST AND FOREMOST.
THE U.S. OFFICE OF INFORMATION.
ALL OF THEM THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE SHOULD MAKE ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR WHAT THESE VPNs ARE THAT
ALLOW YOU TO GET AROUND THESE
FILTERS.
BY THE WAY, THAT SYSTEM IN CUBA
THAT SHUTS DOWN THE INTERNET,
GUESS WHO GAVE IT TO THEM?
CHINA.
CHINA BUILT IT, CHINA INSTALLED
IT AND I BELIEVE CHINA OPERATES
IT ON BEHALF OF THE CUBAN
GOVERNMENT, SO IT'S A CHINESE
SYSTEM THEY ARE USING TO SHUT ON
THE INTERNET BUT I THINK
LONG-TERM IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE
BEEN PUSHING FOR A LONG TIME, WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS ON IT WHEN
TRUMP WAS IN OFFICE AND THAT IS
TO PROVIDE INTERNET ACCESS,
SATELLITE INTERNET ACCESS SO
CUBANS DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE LINES THAT THE CUBAN
GOVERNMENT CAN SHUT ON AND OFF
BUT ACTUALLY USE SATELLITES TO
COMMIT TO GET TO THE WORLD INTO
EACH OTHER.
THAT SHOULD TAKE SOME TIME BUT
THAT SHOULD BE OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY IN TERMS OF WHAT WE CAN
DO TO HELP THE PEOPLE OF CUBA.
>> Sean: MURDERING REGIMES,
THEY'VE GOT ALL THE POWERS.
YOU DON'T WIN REVOLUTIONS WITH
SLINGSHOTS.
I KNOW AMERICANS THAT NOBODY HAS
ANY APPETITE FOR FOREIGN
CONFLICT, BECAUSE THERE ARE WAYS
THAT THE UNITED STATES COULD
HELP THE FREEDOM MOVEMENT IN
CUBA OTHER WAYS TO >> LISTEN,
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
SOMETHING.
WE TALK ABOUT THE CUBAN
MILITARY, THE BULK OF THE CUBAN
MILITARY ARE 17, 18 AND 19 EUROS
THAT ARE FORCED BY LAW TO SERVE
IN THE MILITARY FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS AND WHAT THEY ARE TELLING
THOSE KIDS RIGHT NOW IS LISTEN,
WE'RE GOING TO SEND YOU TO A
TOWN HALFWAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHERE YOU DON'T KNOW ANYONE AND
IF YOU DON'T WORDPRESS PEOPLE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO THE
UNIVERSITY SO THAT'S WHY THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO SAY DO
NOT STAY IN YOUR HANDS AND
BLOOD, DO NOT GO TO ANOTHER TOWN
AND SINGER HAD SOME BLOOD AND
ONE OF THE THINGS I HOPE WE DO
IS START A LIST AND USE THESE
PICTURES FROM ONLINE WE ARE
GETTING WITH NAME AND LAST NAME
HIM OF THESE PEOPLE ARE OUT IN
THE STREET REPRESSING BECAUSE
THEY NEED TO BE BANNED -- A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE END UP COMING TO
AMERICA TO HER THREE YEARS FROM
NOW SAYING A POLITICAL PERSON
OR, I'M FLEEING OPPRESSION BUT
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT WERE PART OF THOSE
REPRESSIVE OPERATIONS IN THE
PAST.
WE HAVE TO KNOW WHO THEY ARE,
IDENTIFY THEM, UNMASK THEM AND
PUT THEM ON A LIST SO NOT ONLY
NOW, BUT IN THE FUTURE THEY HAVE
TO FACE JUSTICE.
>> Sean: IT'S TIME FOR THIS
MURDERING -- MURDERING MARXIST
REGIME TO FALL.
SENATOR, I